I've shared some pretty wild stories
with you guys through the years on this
YouTube channel but I thought we watch a
very popular show called untold stories
of the ER but before we get to it I have
to urge you click that notification bell
and set up all notifications that way
you're sure to get my videos let's get
started these are the real stories of
the ER that doctors never talk about
already I'm gonna call BS on that one
because ER doctors love sharing their
stories this isn't even about ER doctors
doctors love sharing their stories and I
know many people will jump and say what
about HIPAA what about patient privacy
if we don't give the patient's
identifier x' their name their date of
birth a picture of them it's totally
okay to talk about their case otherwise
how in the world would doctors ever
learned we have to talk about cases all
right Scott read I'm a paramedic I said
send the ambulance routine we don't need
lights and sirens we don't need the fire
department just send an ambulance
routine I think she has fainted on the
bathroom floor if this ever happens to
you call 9-1-1 and tell him to bring
everybody in this situation it's quite
specific as he's a paramedic he knows
what's going on
I prefer that right away you call for
help if a person's unconscious and you
aren't sure start chest compressions
that could be the difference between
saving their life and then losing their
life just because you were
self-conscious or weren't sure if you
should do chest compressions if you
aren't sure the person's unconscious
you've called for help
chest compressions chest compressions
chest compressions
we run room with a 38 year old female
who's had a syncopal episode she's
semi-conscious blood pressure is 60 over
40 and dropping okay so that's the most
dangerous part about all of this the
fact that our blood pressure's dropping
means that she's not getting enough
circulation to her vital organs think
brain kidneys liver and when that
happens the only option for us in the
medical community is to give a ton of
fluids to increase the blood pressure
into the circulatory system if that
doesn't work our next resort is to go to
artificial pressors which are basically
adrenaline like medications that cause
all your blood vessels to constrict
really hard to raise the blood pressure
to make sure the blood reaches
everywhere in your body that it's
supposed to if that doesn't happen in
time
that could be a cause of death it's
called shock so basically she's going
into shock and we don't know why the ECG
is stat portable chest x-ray CBC e7
troponin a d-dimer an ABG the stat bits
like the cardiology console and he did
not go right away please okay so all
these tests that he's ordering all make
sense these are all the tests that you'd
want to know
just to possibly get an idea of what's
going on when a patient comes into the
ER you don't know anything you don't
know if they're anemic you don't know if
they have an infection you don't know if
they have a pneumothorax has their lung
collapsed is she having a heart attack
so you need all of these tests done as
quickly as possible so you can slowly
start stabilizing the patient and
creating a course of action she's APNIC
we're gonna lose her beggar beggar so
what a person loses consciousness like
that and they're out of it and you have
to breathe for them right away that's a
sign that that patient may need to be
intubated intubate is when you put a
breathing tube down for them obviously
the most important part of that is to
help them breathe but the second most
important part is to protect their
airway because if she were to vomit then
that vomit can go right into her lungs
and cause even a more serious problem
when a patient is unconscious they don't
have a gag reflex to protect them from
inhaling vomit so that's why we rush
right away to intubate thicker yet for
dr. Christopher mykos does dr. Miko's
needs to tell me what's going on with
his scrubs I like cool scrubs but I
don't know what's happening with those
maybe this episode is from a really long
time ago and those were in then I think
I'm gonna have to make him like send him
a sample of my upcoming scrub line his
face and whole body was covered in hives
and he was retracting his muscles were
being pulled into his chest this is a
critically sick child the serious
medical condition known as anaphylaxis
so two things happen during anaphylactic
shock that are very dangerous one is
that the oral airway starts swelling and
when that happens obviously you can lose
your ability to breathe the second thing
that happens is because you have shock
all of your blood vessels dilate and
therefore it drops your blood pressure
this is another form of shock that can
be quite deadly because again you're not
perfusing and getting blood flow to all
your vital organs anaphylaxis is deadly
that's why we hand out EpiPen to all of
our patients who have gone into
or at risk at going into anaphylaxis
that's why when epi pens are expensive
people can't afford them I get really
mad we gave them additional
antihistamine we gave them intravenous
steroids so antihistamines are great for
an allergic reaction but they don't do
anything to treat the symptoms of
anaphylactic shock what you really want
to do is make sure that the patient has
a secured airway and that they're
getting enough blood flow to all their
vital organs which can mean giving them
a ton of fluids or pressors it was about
3 a.m. on a Saturday night and the bars
have been let out most of the trauma
that you're gonna see has come and gone
and it gets quieter in the ER that's
actually true when you're on call you do
have this eerie silence that starts
setting in around 3:30 4:00 a.m. and
that's usually the time where before our
morning rounds if you're on a 24-hour
shift maybe you can sneak in like a 1
hour nap I will say that after that nap
you tend to feel worse because you wake
up and you're just jarred and you want
to continue sleeping so my general
advice for medical students residents or
anyone who's doing those types of shifts
keep it short do like a 30-minute nap
and then get up and do some work because
if you start entering the REM cycle and
come out too early that can be really
problematic and you'll wake up all
groggy ok Becky get vital let's get them
on the bed
did any of those cuts are they on the
abdomen didn't have them go into lungs
into the stomach anywhere that we need
to deal with right now
the first thing we do in these types of
trauma situations is undress the patient
as quickly as possible because it's very
easy to miss a wound if you don't have
the patient they're completely naked and
that sounds like a weird thing to do but
it if you step one foot into any level 1
trauma center you will see the first
thing doctors do take scissors and cut
off all the clothes we need to see if
they're bleeding from anywhere because
if they have a puncture wound in their
abdomen and we miss it and they're
pooling blood into their abdomen they
can just go ahead and die right in that
moment without us being able to even
help them let's open that chest do that
here the procedure is called a
thoracotomy and it's almost never
performed outside the sterile
environment of an operating room I
never heard of a thoracotomy be
performed in an ER ever Scoville at
least try and create a sterile field
don't just say we're gonna open up her
chest scalpel and she doesn't currently
have a pulse I feel like a lot is
inaccurate in this representation you're
gonna have to talk to the mother you
speak Greek you could eke you speak
could eke my wife is fluent in Greek and
she would be happy to help I'm in a bit
of a situation here and I need your help
can you help me translate so this is
kind of messed up because it is a HIPAA
violation it's like a patient privacy
issue but in an emergent situation
perhaps that could be put on hold what
happens in regular hospitals we have
translator phones for this where one
person picks up one phone and the other
picks up the other and through a
translator or interpreter we can
actually have a normal conversation I
don't know why he needs to call his wife
and get her involved sometimes it's like
a needle in a haystack trying to figure
out what's causing the allergic reaction
if a child is having a severe allergic
reaction an anaphylactic shock it's not
of utmost importance in the ER to figure
out what it was from the most important
thing is to stabilize the patient using
epinephrine and if that fails to put a
breathing tube in and then give steroids
high doses of steroids keep the pressure
up through fluids and/or pressors and
then later down the line we could start
figuring this out I'm surprised he
started doing all this investigation
here lo and behold you know I'm like
looking at the apron and I'm like
thinking food and not because I was
hungry
Papo your apron nuts nuts whenever a
doctor's yelling nuts at you you doing
something wrong stay away from those
nuts he would have to carry an EpiPen to
counteract should he ever come in
contact with nuts again please carry
your epi pens and make sure they're not
expired don't want to be over the
Atlantic Ocean having me stab you with a
giant EpiPen that's not made to be used
as an EpiPen
it's just epinephrine for someone's
heart stopping nurse penny weed has
survived an eight-hour open-heart
surgery feeling that my mom might not be
able to be a normal person again after
all of that was scary
that's the thing when someone loses
their pulse for that long patients
families have questions for us like how
is this gonna affect them are they going
to be the same and
many times we just don't have an
accurate answer so the most honest thing
we can say is we don't know but we'll
hope for the best sometimes people don't
like that but unfortunately medicine is
as much an art as it is a science when I
woke up they told me I'd had open-heart
surgery for blood clots and they told me
I'd had a thoracotomy you don't always
get a lot of victories so it was the
best moment of my career so far that's
one of the great things of being an ER
doctor when you intervene in a patient's
case you get the result in that
gratification right away as a family
medicine doctor a lot of times I'll give
a treatment or a plan that will take
months or years to even come to fruition
when we're talking about weight loss
reducing cancer risks it's not as
instantly gratifying as a surgeon or as
an ER doctor but moments like this are
really really powerful and hard to come
by as doctors Jason Exner still works in
the same small community hospital along
with a new colleague haha I can't
imagine how many puns they share
together hey if you don't get me my
tools I'm gonna take your heart back
okay that was corny sorry the YouTube
algorithm has been a little bit funky
lately so in case you missed my last
three amazing videos click here for the
playlist and as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]